my oldest daughter she had open heart
surgery when she was a year and a half
your range of emotion when you're single
is like 10 on the upper end and zero on
the lower end then you get married and
goes to like 20 on the upper end cuz
when you're with your partner and it's
really happy it's phenomenal and like
netive - 20 cuz if you're at odds or if
something bad is happening to your
partner it's the worst thing in the
world and then you have kids and all
limits are completely removed like by
far the worst things that happen are
with your kids but the best things that
happen are like 3 days ago I've got all
four of my kids they're all in one room
and the baby is little he's like 2
months old and my 3-year-old daughter is
having her hair brushed by her older
sister while my son who seven is reading
them a book and like that's St it's
amazing but when the kids are being
jerks it's really awful